moi c'était un match très difficile
je me suis fait avoir dans les
trois premières parties dans les
ouvertures même ok la quatrième je joue
un nouveau coup qui connaissait c'était
aussi compliqué donc dans la première il
m'a joué nouveautés et
au début j'ai plutôt bien réagi j'ai pas
pris trop de risque y est
il m'a fait une attaque qui marchent pas
et je sais pas bon j'ai beaucoup joué
cet été du coup j'arrive un peu fatigué
mais j'ai fait une erreur et bien sûr
ils étaient gagnants pendant quelques
coups et puis la deuxième il a égalisé
facilement avec les noirs donc voila et
puis là les tie breaks dans la première
j'ai joué quelque chose que j'ai vu il
m'a joué la quarantaine qui jouait pas
d'habitude et puis il était devant dans
les deux dans les deux ouvertures donc
mais après sa valeur dans les parties
plus tôt dans la partie plus technique
de la première partie j'ai plutôt bien
joué même si ça doit être mieux quand
même
moi je suis content d'avoir gagné
c'était vraiment pas facile j'ai joué
bienne
j'ai eu pas mal de boulot championnat
d'espagne par équipes le championnat de
france
zack force à faire beaucoup et j'ai joué
jusqu'à l'âge jusqu'à dimanche dernier
est qu après il fallait préparer un
petit peu ici mais j'ai pas trop le
temps fallait faire le voyage pas mal de
choses à faire et du coup quel premier
tour difficile on verra demain on verra
demain contre bout si j'arrive à mieux
jouer mais c'est sûr que je vais devoir
améliorer un peu mon jeu parce que sinon
je vais pas aller très loin
je joue conte bull au prochain tour gd
on était dans la même catégorie d'âge
quand on était jeune mais j'ai pas joué
beaucoup contre lui en fait je me
souviens plus des résultats complets
[Musique]
si je joue mieux et ça va être un match
serré de toute façon tous les matches
sont serrés mais j'espère jouer mieux et
on verra ça se passe bien merci beaucoup